(faint techno tones)
- We're very, very happy
to have Amy Westling
to kick off our conference this morning.
Amy is the executive
director of the association
of Regional Center Agencies in Sacramento,
also called ARCA and Amy
is gonna give us an update
on what ARCA is doing
these days. So Amy...
- Amy grew up in Sacramento
and if she doesn't give you the thumbs up
for Lady Bird, the movie, I will.
(laughing)
Welcome back.
- Good morning everyone.
Thank you so much for
having me here this morning.
I was sharing with people over
coffee and juice this morning
that I was here last year at
the very tail end of a day
and people were a little bit tired
and so I guess it's sort
of like Icarus pushing,
or not Icarus,
it's the guy who pushed the
rock up the hill, Sisyphus.
It's escaping me this morning,
which tells me it's too early
to really talk about Medicaid.
(audience laughing)
So you'll have to bear with me
and I will do my absolute
best to try to make Medicaid
and the financing of the
services that people rely on
as interesting as possible,
but I'm not working with
terribly compelling information here.
My apologies, I did not provide the staff
with a biography of myself.
I did want to note before
I got started that I,
prior to working at the Association
of Regional Center Agencies
I did work for Central Valley
Regional Center for five years
and I know some of my
Central Valley friends
are in the audience.
I also worked for Alta
California Regional Center
for five years and also worked
for Disability Rights California.
So that's just my way of
saying that this really
is a passion of mine and
unfortunately passion has
to be backed up with financing
and that's why we're all here at 8:00 a.m.
to talk about Medicaid.
Maybe...
Oh, okay, little bit of
a delay probably in me,
not the system.
So Just first things first,
I have no financial
relationships to disclose,
no conflicts of interest
and won't be promoting
any commercial products
or services here today.
Except for of course go see Lady Bird.
(audience laughing)
But I don't have a
financial interest in that,
so I think that's okay.
Fantastic coming-of-age story
about a young girl being
raised in our state's capital.
This morning we're gonna
talk about the basics
of federal Medicaid rules,
special Medicaid programs
and really the heart of it all;
how we can advocate for the
essential Medicaid programs
that people with developmental
disabilities rely on.
So first let's talk about
the basics of Medicaid.
Medicaid began in 1965.
It was and is a federal
program that was developed
at the same time that
Medicare was developed.
The goal, the stated goal of the program
is to improve a range of health
and medical services for
Americans of all ages.
It and Medicare came along
at a time when medical costs
were increasing, medical
complexities were increasing
and prior to this most
families were on their own
when it came to taking
care of medical issues.
Here in California we like
to make everything special
and unique and branded for ourselves,
so we call it Medi-Cal,
but in most other states
it's known as Medicaid except for Kansas,
where it is called KanCare.
Isn't that cute?
(audience laughing)
And really at its core, it is
about providing key supports
and services to people through a state
and federal funding partnership
and we know that the federal government
when they pay for something
have strings attached.
So we're gonna talk a little bit
about what some of those strings are.
I was at a budget hearing yesterday
and really the message
that we all took home was
that we're well past the point
in any government funding where
you can say, "give us money
"and we'll go do good things,"
and Medicaid is no exemption.
So who qualifies for Medicaid?
This is gonna become important later.
All states are required
to cover certain populations in Medicaid.
First are families with minor children
who are living under the
federal poverty level.
The additional population that's required
is individuals with disabilities on SSI.
And usually people with
developmental disabilities
find Medicaid eligibility,
especially adults,
through the second category.
Some states through the
Affordable Care Act chose
to expand Medicaid eligibility,
including California,
and we provided Medicaid eligibility
to individuals at a slightly
higher income level 138%
of federal poverty level as
well as childless adults.
Medicaid is funded, as I mentioned,
through a state and federal
financing partnership.
In government we have to
have acronyms for everything,
so FMAP is the state's percentage
of federal reimbursement
for its Medicaid services.
California and about 14
other states have a 50% FMAP
and this means for every two
dollars that California spends
in Medicaid services
the federal government
reimburses the state one dollar.
A state's FMAP percentage is determined
by its overall economic prosperity.
So California and about 14 other states
are at the lowest end of FMAP,
because they are the most
prosperous economically.
I looked it up this morning
and the state with the
highest FMAP is Mississippi.
In Mississippi, the FMAP, it's over 75%.
So to put it in context,
for every four dollars
that Mississippi spends
on Medicaid services
they get three federal dollars back.
Additionally, there's an
old virtue in government
that you pay for what
you want to see more of.
So there are little bonus FMAPs for things
that the federal government
wants to see more of,
to incentivize states to make changes.
For example, when we were
talking a couple of minutes ago
about the Affordable Care
Act expansion population,
the way that the federal
government incentivized states
to expand funding and expand eligibility
to that population was
through changing the FMAP
for those populations.
So for instance, in the early years
of the Affordable Care
Act some of those programs
were reimbursed at 90%, even
if the state's FMAP was 50%.
So there were huge incentives
for states to jump on board,
but we know not all states did.
The federal government, as I mentioned,
has strings that they
attach to Medicaid funding.
Each state must submit what are
called State Plan Amendments
to the federal government
for review and consideration.
A State Plan Amendment outlines how
and under what circumstances
services will be provided
and those are known as SPAs because again,
we need acronyms for everything.
It's important to know
that a SPA is a service
that is provided to all eligible people
who are Medicaid eligible
within the state.
The Centers for Medicare
and Medicaid Services,
again we have an acronym,
but this one's weird because
there should be two M's,
it's CMS, approves, denies or
comments on SPA applications.
This is how the federal
government controls the quality
and expectations for
services that are provided.
Fun fact, the Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid Services
used to be called Healthcare
Financing Administration,
but it sounded too bureaucratic
and the acronym for that
was pronounced, Hick-fah.
(audience laughing)
So CMS kind of rolls off
the tongue a little better.
So there are four basic rules in Medicaid:
First, whatever a state puts in their
State Plan Amendments must
be provided statewide.
There must be comparable services,
so there have to be standards that explain
in what instances
services will be provided.
And those services are then available
to everyone who's a Medicaid recipient
who needs those services
and meets the criteria.
There have to be reasonable promptness,
so you have to have time
and distance requirements
for meeting needs and there
must be provider choice.
So you can't say, "this
is our orthopedist,
"take it or leave it,"
for an entire state.
There are different
mandatory benefits for adults
and children with the
belief at the federal level
that children with appropriate services
and supports can reach their
developmental potential.
But for adults there's
a very specific list
of the things that Medicaid
is required to pay for.
For children, it's a much
broader, much softer kind of list
and it's provided through
a program called EPSDT
which stands for
Early Periodic Screening
Diagnostic and Treatment.
I believe that the next speakers will go
into a little more detail on this,
but it really is a scheme
whereby children are supposed
to receive services that they
need and including screenings
and diagnostic work and
that they're supposed
to receive treatment to address
their developmental needs.
So there aren't supposed
to be these hard caps
on services like you will often find
in the adult service system.
So let's talk about what services
are actually mandatory for adults.
Inpatient and outpatient
hospital services,
nursing facilities, home health,
physician, family nurse
practitioner services,
laboratory and X-ray
services, family-planning,
birth center, nurse midwife
and tobacco cessation
only if you're pregnant
and transportation to
medical care, that's it.
Those are the mandatory services.
But states are allowed to go beyond
that to provide what are
called optional benefits.
If you're looking at this
list you can probably think
of a lot of holes that would exist
in a state if those are
the only guarantees,
if those are the only medical safety net
for adults eligible for Medicaid.
So let's talk a little
bit about other services.
When you see the list of
optional services you'll go,
"Oh my goodness, I can't imagine a state
"not providing some of these."
So for example, prescription
drug coverage is not mandatory.
Physical speech occupational therapy,
rehabilitative services, podiatry,
optometry and eyeglasses,
dental care, private duty nursing,
inpatient psychiatric services
for two specific populations
and Hospice care.
So California has gone
well beyond the list
of mandatory services and provides many
of these optional benefits as well.
Okay, so those are the basic foundations
and now we're gonna talk a little deeper
into Medicaid theory and practice.
I know everyone was
looking forward to this.
(audience laughing)
So optional benefits; I
wanted to highlight a few
of the optional benefits
that I didn't have
on the prior list that
really are key and critical
for individuals with
developmental disabilities.
One of the optional
benefits is personal care.
Here in California we provide this as
In-Home Supportive Services
which is personal care
that an individual directs themselves
through the IHSS program.
They select their own providers.
They manage their staff themselves.
It's system that is developed
to help people to remain
in their homes rather than
an institutional setting.
So remember I said the federal
government sometimes puts out
little Easter eggs to
make states do things,
encourage not make?
The community first choice option
known as the 1915(k) State Plan Amendment
is one of those things.
So in this program it targets
people who have a level
of care that would otherwise
put them potentially
in a nursing facility,
and it allows for the
provision of services
such as personal care through this program
at an increased FMAP
of 56 rather than 50%.
You may be thinking,
"Wow that's a lot to do
"for six additional percentage points."
But it is something that
the state of California
was doing for the most part
anyway through our IHSS program
and so for eligible individuals
we created a 1915(k) program
to seize that additional 6%
which amounts to hundreds
of millions of dollars in
the state of California.
An additional optional
benefit is case management.
California, again, provides
this through a program called
Targeted Case Management
and there are various community agencies
that provide this service
such as Regional Centers
and other service systems.
Services in an intermediate
care facility for individuals
with intellectual disability,
that's another benefit that
we provide here in California.
And then I wanna talk briefly
about the State Plan Home
and Community Based Services
or the 1915(i) State Plan Amendment.
So this is a service that is provided only
to individuals with a
developmental disability
and the definition that was
used is the same definition
that was used for Regional
Center eligibility.
It allows the state to capture
significant federal dollars
for the provision of
Regional Center services,
things like residential
care, supported living,
transportation, a whole array of services
that previously the
state hadn't found a way
to bill the federal government
for, for certain populations.
We'll talk a little bit
more in a few minutes
about how the state is
recovering federal funds
for other populations
supported by Regional Centers,
but I did want to put it on your radar
that this was a program that
was developed as a result
of the Affordable Care
Act that allowed the state
to capture additional federal dollars
for Regional Center services.
So those are all State Plan Amendments.
State Plan Amendments
are those things you have
to provide to people
as long as they meet the
basic eligibility criteria.
But beginning in 1981 the
federal government decided
that states could waive
certain Medicaid requirements.
Remember we talked about there
needs to be comparability,
there needs to be a statewidedness,
there needs to be a whole
variety of guarantees
to people in the Medicaid population.
But beginning in the
80s states could waive
certain Medicaid requirements
and we call these programs
where there's a waiver
of requirements, we came up
with the catchy name of waivers.
So the 1915(c) waiver allows
for the waiver of comparability
and statewidedness to provide home
and community-based services.
What this means is that this
type of waiver allows the state
to provide services just
to a specific population
and that population is then entitled
to a very specific package of services
that's not available to the
broader Medicaid population.
So in California our
biggest 1915(c) waiver
is our developmental disabilities waiver
and it allows for people who are served
by the Regional Center who
have significant deficits
in life skills to receive
services and for the state
to receive reimbursement
from the federal government
at a 50% match for those services.
Now we talked a little
bit, a few minutes ago
about the 1915(i) State Plan Amendment
and what that did was allow the state
to bill for these same services,
but for people who did
not meet the criteria
for the states developmental
disabilities waiver.
So maybe it was people who,
they didn't meet criteria
for admission to an ICF facility,
which is one of the
requirements of the 1915(c),
you have to say if not for these services
this person may be supported
in this other environment.
Whereas the 1915(i) is much broader.
So together the 1915(i) and
the 1915(c) allow for the state
to recoup approximately 40% of the cost
of Regional Center services
and supports to people
and this a huge deal
because we're operating
in a system that's well north
of six billion dollars today.
About 2 1/2 billion dollars
is coming from the federal
government to support our system.
There are some rules about waivers.
As I mentioned, they
allow for the provision
of additional services.
The services must be cost-effective,
so if you are providing
services it has to be cheaper
on the aggregate than
providing those same services
to people in an institutional setting.
States can cap enrollment on their waivers
and each person is
limited to participation
in only one waiver.
So many states control the size
of their developmental disability system
by capping enrollment in their waiver.
In California we have, I
think last time I checked,
somewhere around 140,000
people on our waiver,
but other states cap their
waivers not based on demand,
but based on fiscal realities.
So there are states that say,
hey of course you're entitled
to waiver services through
basically their structure
that looks something
like Regional Centers,
as soon as a slot opens up.
So there are states in this country
where individuals can wait
for services for decades.
So one of the things we always
talk about in California
is that we pride ourselves
on there's not a wait at the front door.
There's not the acknowledgment of a need
and then people being turned away
until someone exits the waiver
by either moving out of
state or passing away.
We don't do that.
We always talk about this entitlement
and it's a very lofty
thing that we talk about,
but we need to recognize
that's the impact.
In California, people who have
a developmental disability
can apply for services
and if found eligible
can receive the services they need.
In other states people apply for services
and are told absolutely you qualify
and we'll get back to you.
So this is a huge deal.
I wanna talk for a moment
about Katie Beckett.
Katie is a reminder that one person,
one individual story,
can make a huge fundamental difference.
So when Katie was four
months old she got very sick
and at the end of her illness
she ended up being dependent
on a ventilator many hours of the day,
and the weird way that
federal Medicaid rules work,
if a child lives at
home with their family,
the family's income is considered
when determining if the
child is Medicaid eligible.
But if a child lives on their own,
in this case in a hospital,
their family size is one.
It is only that child that is considered,
because they're not considered
to be living with their family.
Katie's family wasn't
a family of high means,
but was high enough not
to qualify for Medicaid
and so Katie lived continuously
in a hospital for three years,
because if she left that hospital
she would rejoin her family
and she would no longer
qualify for any services.
It's interesting because, at the time,
Katie's care in inpatient hospitalization
was think about 6,000 dollars a month.
I would love to see us
return to those days, right?
Where 6,000 dollars gets
you a month of hospital stay
with ventilator dependence.
But nonetheless her care at home
would've been 1,000 dollars.
Her mother pushed the issue and raised it
and pushed the federal government
and the story made it all
the way to President Reagan
who said, "This is ridiculous."
Based on Katie, the
Institutional Deeming Program
was created where children
with significant disabilities
can qualify for Medicaid
regardless of family income
to allow those children to stay at home.
At the time the belief was that one
or 200 kids would be helped,
we've hit half a million children
that Katie's journey has touched.
So this brings us to what
can we do about all this?
We hear a lot of discussion
at the federal level about Medicaid.
How many people watched the debates
in December where legislators
were talking about,
we need to do something about Medicaid
and we need to fix it and we
need to do all these things?
What you heard a lot about was the desire
to control costs in the Medicaid program,
but I will tell you when people
think about Medicaid outside
of our arena, if we close our eyes
and think about somebody
we know who's on Medi-Cal
we probably are thinking about people
with developmental disabilities
because that's our reality.
But lawmakers weren't thinking about that.
They were thinking about
the other population.
People who are on Medicaid because
of low socioeconomic status.
So a lot of these debates went on and on.
Additionally, another uncertainty
is always the state budget.
We saw during the recession the cutting
of benefits that were optional.
Things like adult dentistry.
Things like eyeglasses.
Those kinds of things
where the state made tough,
tough decisions related
to those optional benefits
it would provide.
So those are some of the
uncertainties in our world.
It's important that people
who know the reality
of individuals with
developmental disabilities
and their families and the supports
that are oftentimes needed,
it's important that we become
part of that conversation,
that we stay informed,
that we get engaged,
that people tell their own stories
and at the end of the
day that we all show up.
So I spend a lot of my life
reading political commentary
and I sit there with my
hot tea in the morning
and I read and read and
read politico in the papers
and all of this and it can
be a little bit overwhelming.
Has anyone else been
overwhelmed by the news
and the politics lately?
So here's what I want you to do.
I don't want you to just say forget it,
throw up your hands and give it up.
Find some trusted
sources and stay engaged,
stay informed, but don't obsess about it.
Don't sit there and
wring your hands and say,
"What are we going to do?"
Because action planning is next.
But find sources you trust, read those,
stay on top of it and put it away.
But keep it in the back of
your head and keep track
of when important things are coming up
in healthcare policy debates.
First and foremost,
you need to know your representatives are.
You can go to the Assembly
or Aenate website here
in California or the
website for the Senate
or the House of Representatives.
Find out who your representatives are
and then do something
remarkable, go out and meet them.
They hold events in your communities.
Our state-level representatives
often hold the coffee get
together kinds of things.
Call or write, get to know them.
And then when there are
key votes coming up,
call or write to them.
It's not because one
person's voice is going
to make a difference,
(clearing throat) excuse me,
it's because so few people
actually pick up that phone
that for every phone call they get
they assume there's 100 people
just like you sitting in their districts.
Call them.
When you tell your story
there are some guidelines,
but first and foremost, know
that stories are powerful,
know that there are people who are paid
to work Capitol Hill who wear suits,
who look very professional
and who are a dime a dozen.
But know that you are the
expert in your own story
and that those stories of real life people
are the most compelling.
When you tell your story be
short, be clear, be truthful,
be constructive, focused and memorable.
Don't hide the lead, put it out in front,
but also let them know
what it is you need.
Let them know what it is
that makes a difference
in the lives of either
yourself or your family members
or the people you support,
because those things,
those things make a difference
and they make an impact.
When people work in legislative settings
they are so removed
oftentimes from what I like
to call real people,
because they don't get the opportunity
to spend time hearing from actual people
who are impacted by policies,
so those things are very, very powerful.
Showing up, find out when the hearings are
and go if you can.
It was interesting during last
fall's health care debate,
one of the most effective
groups is a group called ADAPT.
Has anyone heard of them?
One of the things they did
was try to change the face
of a Medicaid recipient in people's minds
and they were very effective.
These are people who have
significant disabilities who came
in wheelchairs and staged
what they called a die-in.
They removed themselves
from their wheelchairs
and refused to get up and
many of them got arrested,
but they sent a message
that a few people can be very powerful.
And they shifted the
debate to remind people
that when you're talking
about a Medicaid recipient
you're talking about a whole
swath of our population
and that you need to understand
that when you're looking
at dollars and cents that you're talking
about real people's lives
and their support needs
and that those things have value.
So go to hearings if you can.
Additionally, watch for
hearings outside of Sacramento
or Washington, sometimes
there are hearings
that take place in other locations.
Find public meetings or
forums where your legislators
are going to be, they will remember you.
Thank you so much.
(audience clapping)